[Musique]
bonjour federica bonjour jimmy madame
monsieur bonjour l'invité donc de 5 à 10
ce matin le sénateur maurice antiste
bonjour bonjour
alors hier le gouvernement a lancé le
grenelle des violences conjugales
quelques annonces ont été faites parmi
lesquelles la création de places
d'hébergement d'urgence supplémentaires
milles environ et la mise en place de
bracelets d'éloignement porté par le
conjoint violent ce grenelle est une
action nécessaire
bien heureusement oui elle et elle est
nécessaire parce que nous sommes dans
une véritable dans une véritable urgence
cette violence non contrôlés faites aux
femmes nous pose problème dans la
société et j'ai indiqué à l'occasion de
d'une invitation de ces mêmes femmes
je leur ai indiqué qu'il y a qu'il y a
deux types de travaux ce dans l'urgence
qu'il faut vite mettre en place réalisée
mais aussi un travail à plus long terme
qui devrait commencer chez les tout
petits
parce qu'il n'est pas normal que que que
l'on grandisse avec cette conception de
la femme dans la société qui n'est bonne
qu'à faire la vaisselle qui n'est bonne
qu'à qu'a subie au contraire que la mère
martiniquaise elle même ne doit pas
revoir son l'éducation et en finir avec
le mâle dominant le coq de la basse cour
on a déjà entendu c'est bien ce que
j'expliquais lors de cette intervention
et qu' il y à deux niveaux
d'intervention le niveau d'urgence et le
niveau aussi de l'éducatif
parce que c'est vrai écoutez je suis
enseignant je leur ai dit je leur disais
dernièrement que j'ai fait des petits
sondages au niveau des sixièmes ben
c'est impressionnant là là là l'image
que ces petits ont dû couple du de de la
vie commune etc
c'est déjà et fruits et c'est des
clichés qui sont dangereux et dans dans
la conception des enfants ça nous
interpelle c'est c'est l'homme coque
effectivement et la femme
je ne vis pas avec elle elle est avec
les enfants et je viens quand je veux et
avec tous ces géants plus véhiculer à
travers
chauvigny sociaux les jeunes ont de plus
en plus accès avec les portables très
jeune aux réseaux sociaux
écoutez moi je vais vous dire que je
suis choquée pas pas par l'accès facile
de ses petits enfants de ces jeunes aux
différents actes sexuels
c'est un 7 1 g un véritable drame qui se
joue dans sur le subconscient des
enfants vous savez on est en train de
voler les réseaux sociaux sont en train
de voler littéralement c'était ducasse
yankee qui devrait être normal
progressive la découverte de la femme
la découverte de l'échangé avec la femme
est aujourd'hui la femme n'est qu'un
objet pop ou pour le petit qui n'a pas
eu cette chance de faire sa propre
éducation sont qui n'a pas eu la chance
d'évoluer dans le rapport avec la femme
et c'est dramatique ce qui se passera et
ce grenelle est ce qu'ils ne risquent
pas d'être une coquille vide
ah tiens parce que parce qu'il ya déjà
beaucoup d'associations féministes et de
défense des femmes qui se disent déçus
notamment par le manque de budget le
manque de moyens effectifs c'est ça
enfin je me mets à la place du
gouvernement ça m'est très difficile un
jeu vous vous êtes pas du tout quand
enfin on peut quand même pas cracher
yeux des réactions qui sont proposés
bien sûr on est long et très loin du
compte puisque et par ricochet 6-3 la
martinique
on est très loin du compte mais prenons
toujours ce qu'on nous donne prenant
toujours
et puis continuera à lutter pour
continuer à demander que ce que ce
dossier soit traité avec beaucoup plus
de sérieux et notamment chez nous parce
que un problème traité là-bas et étant
nine adéquation presque je devrais dire
avec ceux qui sont ici les problèmes
sont dédoublés chaque fois plus de sites
internet
chez nous quand même ouais et et 6,6 en
pleine forme être autant qu'ils ne sont
pas réalisés c'est je vous dis que c'est
un véritable drame
la place qu'on laisse à la femme dans la
société et je dirais même qu'il ya aussi
des hommes
il ya aussi des hommes qui sont très mal
considérés de la faire autrement dit ce
combat là n'est pas un combat des femmes
pour des femmes
c'est un combat d d'êtres humains pour
améliorer les rapports dans une société
est la nôtre et concerne parlons
toujours de violence une quinzaine de
morts par arme à feu depuis le début de
l'année et au moins un mort par semaine
depuis le mois de juillet ayez un
silence assourdissant du préfet de
l'état et du gouvernement
enfin je ne suis pas totalement d'autres
avis on peut pas dire que que le silence
et on vous a répondu vous avez vous avez
créé une laine est ce qu'on vous a
répondu à maintenant non pas encore non
mais rassurez-vous ceux qui me
connaissent savent bien que je ne suis
pas là pour défendre qui que ce soit
j'ai mes positions qui sont des
positions clairement martiniquaise et je
me bats pour mon pays pour son
développement mais mais je ne peux pas
dire non plus que rien n'a été fait on
ne fait pas suffisamment on ne fait pas
assez vite et c'est vrai que on a l'air
de ne pas savoir par quel bout prendre
le sujet mais je suis très interpol est
effectivement très stable et pas ce
sujet qui sans qui il n'aurait pas ce
qu'on vous dit qu'on ne sait pas à
grenoble par quel bout ça veut dire
qu'il n'y certaines étaient impuissants
face à la situation actuelle peindre des
des autorités oui des autorités oui mais
j'espère qu'ils cliquent inc y en aura
plus en tout cas ce problème de violence
et nous interpelle à plus haut lieu
parce que nous sommes victimes nous
sommes début va je sais pas si vous vous
rappelez la fonction de bus va c'est de
l'absorber de l'étape d'absorber mais
j'ai l'impression que nous absorbons
tout ce qui nous vient d'enlever le
buvard oui mais dans le redressement ne
relâche on leur trouvera la surtension
nous même si noël est donc ça s'appelle
un une profonde réflexion je crois une
profonde réflexion politique et sociale
sur le fonctionnement de ce pays dans
une instance internationale qu'est
devenu votre courrier vous avez envoyé
un courrier
gouvernement qu'est devenu ce courrier
alors gl réponse on vous a donné
on ne nous a pas encore répondu c'est
normal non c'est pas normal mais mais
mais le fait est qu'aucun concert
mobilisés mais entre temps il ne faut
pas continuer à compter que sur l'autre
que sur l'ailleurs mais ce concours il
suffit en termes de mobilisation parce
que y'a un cône même quand même une
marche contre la violence à fort de
france n'a pas eu d'élu il n'y a pas eu
de parlementaires lors de cette marge
mais il ya eu d'autres moments de
mobilisation où les élus étaient là on
ne peut pas dire que les élus sont
totalement sont totalement absents en
tout cas c'est pas c'est pas une affaire
d'élus seulement c'est une affaire
d'engagement de tous ceux qui sont à des
postes de responsabilité et le premier
poste de responsabilité c'est celui
celui du couple qui met au monde un
enfant si le premier poste de
responsabilité et je crois que
l'éducation est fondamentale dans le
règlement de nos problèmes mais pas
seulement
alors il ya une mobilisation contre la
violence il a circulé à la circulation
par bondy des armes à feu aujourd'hui à
volga plage vous y serez je n'ai pas
encore été invité mais si on met vite
pourquoi pas il faut des gens doivent y
est invité oui mais il faut que je sois
au courant mais mais c'est même pas la
question
la question est plutôt de qu'est ce que
l'on fait là où on est qu'est ce que
chaque fai la wii et la martinique c'est
d'abord l'endroit où je vis ce n'est pas
la peine que je quitte le françois et
que j'ai une manifestation à schoelcher
alors qu françois la violence existe
aussi alors nous demander et lefrançois
qu'est ce qu'on fait à bien oui on
essaie de se mobiliser
on essaie de se mobiliser là où on vit
parce que c'est le pays c'est un grand
carrelage ou sharks s'occupe de son cas
au cccc un meilleur maillage
ah ben oui y'a un moment forcément à une
forcément mais bon on en est pas encore
là alors à bord dont le dossier de
l'université qui effectue sa rentrée le
député la députée bardon josette manin
qui mène une mission d'évaluation des
université des antilles et de guyane
est persona non grata en guadeloupe cela
vous interpelle ça me choque
je suis profondément choquée je crois
que c'est que c'est une manoeuvre dont
on peut à peine voilée la réalité le
président dieu en guadeloupe le
président guadeloupéen de l'université
jusqu'à 16 go clé où il laisse entendre
que keane absolument rien contre les
martiniquais n'ont rien contre madame
anne
il veut simplement attirer l'attention
que ça manque de parité
et qui auraient dû avoir aussi aux
parlementaires guadeloupéen moi ça
m'amuse savage et du président ça
m'amuse je penserai qu'à ce niveau là
nous n'étions plus que des guadeloupéens
que des martiniquais l'université cette
université des antilles des antilles
alors moi je crois que c'est certain que
ce n'est pas très sérieux ce qui se
passe là l'essentiel c'est que des
parlementaires du milieu parce qu'il
n'est pas seul dans la commission madame
anne est il ya aussi un représentant 2,2
du parlement français et je crois que
c'est faire et juin peu à notre
représentation que de s'en prendre à
madame manet et je ne crois pas qu'elle
sera très heureuse de cette situation
dont on fait une erreur là encore parce
qu on est quand je vous parlais tout à
l'heure de bus va bien là encore nous
sommes les victimes de nous mêmes en
nous on nous on cherche à nous diviser
on cherche à mettre à zizanie entre nous
et on cherche donc à nous affaiblir et
nous tombons dans le piège aux richesses
dont naples a sacrifié l'université sur
l'autel de l'idéologie politique
autonomiste
avec le départ de la guyane sous la
pression de madame taubira alors que
l'hexagone que dans l'hexagone c'est
tout le contraire
les universités se regroupent oui mais
non plus long qu l'hexagone fait plus
près de nous regarder la austin dix
utilisent aussi 17 universités
extraordinaire qui dans un succès qui a
déjà des prix nobel et pourtant qui se
définit par son éclatement sur le
territoire mais nous commettons une
erreur toutes les fois où nous allons
nous diviser nous sommes les propres
bourreaux de 2,2 de notre avenir de nous
mêmes et c'est cela que je veux attirer
l'attention c'est sérieux nous sommes
des jouets dans les mains de l'autre et
il faut qu'on arrête ça il faut il faut
qu'on mène des combats unis
ça c'est un pas autant il nous reste
très peu de temps parlant des
municipales au françois
on dit que le mpf le mouvement populaire
franciscain est en perte de vitesse ou
françois et que l'on parle et que voilà
que la population est prête à changer de
cap
oui peut-être enfin en dit beaucoup bon
j'ai pas en tout cas le mpf on peut le
traduit aussi mouvement plus fort plus
fort que jamais je crois que c'est ça et
les gens les gens analyse situations en
fonction des hommes je ne suis plus
maire mais je dis que nous soutenons à
fond on se dit l'ancien le mpf trou de
l'allier qui te candidat parfait qui le
candidat qu'il nous fallait et je dis
donc aux franciscains puisque vous
m'interrogez entente franciscain que
cette campagne je la ferai comme je n'en
ai jamais fait et on peut compter sur
moi pour amener claudie lagier son
équipe et tous ces jeunes qui lanto vais
vers le succès connaissant mes primes
aussi maurice antiste j'ouvre merci
passé une excellente journée à l'école
de nos programmes
merci
[Musique]